[Music]
Taylor Swift the singer is due in
federal court in Denver as day 1 of the
civil trial with a former radio host
begins is it a slam dunk case to prove
he touched her inappropriately here's
what to expect from this Swift legal
battle Taylor's attorney had no comment
as he walked into court to begin jury
selection
Taylor Swift was also inside but dodged
cameras et producer Tracey dela Rosa is
at the courthouse opening arguments in
the jury trial are expected to begin
tomorrow it's unclear what Jace will
testify her fans are also expected to
line miss Teresa at the courthouse but
there's limited space inside there are
only 32 seats reserved for spectators
form a disk jockey David Mueller sued
Swift claiming he lost his job after the
singer said he groped her she
countersued claiming sexual assault in
the suit Swift says Mueller touched her
inappropriately at a meet-and-greet
before this Denver concert Mueller has B
M Utley denied it my hand was never
under her skirt I never grabbed her
Taylor responded in her deposition it
was not an accident
it was completely intentional and I have
never been so sure of anything in my
life legal analyst Dan Abrams says
Taylor's testimony is critical I think
the only way that he wins this case is
if she's a terrible witness and she's
already been deposed and did fine
so it's unlikely in the end it's what
she says and how she says it that's
gonna matter Mueller is seeking three
million dollars in damages in Taylor's
countersuit she says she's suing simply
to prove a point and that she wants to
quote serve as an example to other women
the trial is expected to last two weeks
and if Taylor wins she says that she'll
donate the money to charitable
organizations dedicated to protecting
women from sexual assault
you
you